before we head down to e3 we had a
chance to play some fortnight fortnight
has been in development for some time by
Epic Games and finally has a release
date it's July 25th this gameplay is the
later stages of a newer story based
night mission for context fortnight is a
game where players spawn in explore an
open map and then end each mission with
wave defence exploration is where you
rescue survivors and find blueprints to
craft permanent gear guns and traps you
can also find temporary guns that will
eventually break on top of the simple
exploration / wave defense concept is a
fairly complex stat survivor management
meta you find collect and promote
survivor cards in order to give your
team passive stat boosts you can also
find or unlock multiple player
controlled survivors with unique skill
sets such as builders and soldiers I get
the impression you'll know if this game
is your thing very quickly if you do the
multiple skill progression trees are
extensive and would keep you busy for
some time before we get to the gameplay
one quick note we're about to bring you
some major triple-a announcements like
battlefront - state of decay - and
battlefield one dlc from e3 so
subscribing to our channel will get you
all that info as fast as possible thanks
for watching
yeah
we got monsters
[Applause]
okay ambos running dangerously low here
Oh
look out
Oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
No
thirty seconds left to go
nicely done commander
[Music]
you